Speaker 1: Where did it start for you when you are now 24, 25, 24? So where did it start?
Speaker 2: I was starting in my fifth standard. At my age you can say around eight or nine, something.
My father used to give to me some of the remote control control toy cars. Unlike other kids, I like to play with it.
I like to play and try to enjoy it and get happiness through it. But personal this haunts me that why?
Why it is working like this? I always keep asking myself, why? Where? What? Where? When?
I keep on asking such questions that keeps
Speaker 2: [INAUDIBLE] in my mind.
So because I had been taught in my first standard
or second standard in my early childhood days that current flows from battery to the model through a wire
and through a switch. If you activate the switch the current flows from the battery to the model.
But here the [INAUDIBLE] remote control car, there's a remote there's a car. There's no wires only antennas.
How the current is flowing? So that was really curious for me.
And in the beginning I got shocked, that why it is happening?.
It might be some ghost might have entered inside the car because I used to watch like ghost movies [INAUDIBLE]
That's why it is working in that way.
And after two days or three days, I tried to explore that how this ghost exactly looks like. So I thought that.
And I know that to hack any smaller maybe [INAUDIBLE] gadgets, one small instrument is required and that is a tester.
Small screwdriver, I just got somewhere,and just untighten the screws. Open the box, and said wow.
That was a really interesting thing for me which really attracted me
and created a passion towards me towards technology and gadgets.
So I just saw, I just explored, I just pulled out the circuit, and I just saw and wow.
That is something which I was expecting. So I just, after my expectations for I'm glad, I'm satisfied that, yes.
And then finally I tried to place it back, put back the cover of the car, I just tightened the screw.
And I tried to switch on the remote.
So yeah, one day I was in my home, and my parents were out for the shopping and
when I was 11 my mind kept exploring kept wondering what next to do.
Other kids in other activity but I was noticed in hacking gadgets and on, that was my passion from my childhood.
So I saw now what to hack, one to have. My father stopped giving me and he kind of such toys, but now what to hack?
So one television, one TV, and that television fascinated me,
that was what that would be because in the small toy car there was electric circuit.
So how big that electric circuit would be, in that box type TV.
And those days we don't do have LCD type TVs because at least a couple of, 10 to 15 years back,.
we used to have that big box type TV and it has a [INAUDIBLE] That that we used to have those days.
So I assumed it was that. I know just to hack those gadgets, one small instrument is required and that is tester.
I just got it from somewhere and again I untightened the screw. When I just opened the box I said wow.
That was really for me. I like I just. Exclaimed that, wow.
This is something general, I got like something a treasury, this is a treasure for me.
Then I just, I just, like, I'm collecting all the golds and diamonds, but it wasn't really gold and diamonds for me.
I am all the circuits and I'm just pulling all the circuits and wires and everything and [INAUDIBLE] I got a shock.
I just checked that the power was off [INAUDIBLE]
realized because I don't during that time I didn't have any electronics knowledge.
[INAUDIBLE] So [INAUDIBLE] that was a capacitor which holds.
And [INAUDIBLE] subtracting [INAUDIBLE] experience, I mean [INAUDIBLE] knowledge.
So, I'm wondering, I just got completely lost in that circuit.
I'm just completely excited, I was completely passionate towards that one [INAUDIBLE] and everything.
I was completely involved in that. Then the start of I heard a beep sound.
I just stopped what I was doing just peeped through the window and I saw my parents came.
Without wasting a single time I just packed all the circuits and all the wires as fast as possible.
I just put back the box, back in the screw, jump to the bed holding the book upside down. [SOUND] And parents came in.
Then my father. Something is not common. Something I notice my kid has done.
I just see that he's holding the book upside down. Something notorious activity he has done.
Let's see what he has done. So my father, just forgetting everything, just asked for the dinner.
Cuz that was around late night, around 10 PM you can say. So my mom dinner later on, first the.
Because Indians are more into daily soaps and on.
Indian normally more into daily soaps and also my mom can skip dinner, can't skip that's what in their sasbo reels,
that daily soap serials. So first that, so my mom just relaxed on her bed.
Power on the plug of the TV, put the remote [INAUDIBLE] press the power button.
[SOUND] One corner of my house was on fire. All my neighbors, all my relatives, they're bringing the sand and water.
I was like yes I did it. I am the scientist yes I did it. I just screamed like anything, yes I did it.
I'm the scientist.
Because that time I had the knowledge that the person who does something or pressing something it blasted.
Then you've got a scientist.
I knew that was the meaning of a scientist when I was a kid so I was screaming like anything.
And then all my parents, all my relatives, all the neighbors they came to me.
I thought they were coming to applaud me what I have done.
But that applaud was in such a way that my stomach was completely filled with all the scoldings, all the screamings,
whatever they can do. So my dinner was completely done that day.
And from that day onwards, I was kept away from all the circuits, all the gadgets.
Everything even after a few days even if you come to my neighbors, any of the neighboring house and say [INAUDIBLE]
is coming to your home. And they'll first keep aside the gadgets [INAUDIBLE] something's coming. Hacking of the gadget.
So away from him. So that was when I was [INAUDIBLE] passion towards technology and all.
But gradually my passion towards innovation happen by an accident you can say.
Because I never thought that I should make an innovation.
I was fascinated and I was passionate towards technology, gadgets and all. But then when the innovation is an accident.,
And that happens in the, with that.,
When I was in my [INAUDIBLE] when I was 16 years old, I had gone to the hospital with my father.
I mean my father generally used to have high blood pressure and he goes for a weekly check-up.
So one day I accompanied him to the hospital and the clinic you can say, not a hospital.
It's more [INAUDIBLE] type of clinic and my father just entered inside the [INAUDIBLE] and I waited outside..
So after those few minutes I saw that my eyes [INAUDIBLE] Because of the old age his hands
and movements were restricted and paralysis might have happened for that.
So I was seeing that he was sitting on a wheelchair and then he was being assisted by a nurse all the time from here,
there. So I was just observing what was happening.
And I just found that the person was not able to speak because later I came to know that 70% of disabled people lose
their vocal power because of that paralysis, spinal injury, a little spinal inactiveness.
I mean this [INAUDIBLE] happen so I saw that he was not able to express what he exactly wants..
He was slightly able to raise his hands but not able to express [INAUDIBLE] So he was slightly with his hand
or he might be require water or something. So I handed him a glass of water and he just threw it down.
He want something else. So seeing that really hurts me. I just put myself in that position.
That if someone's brain was working everything working but due to body inactiveness.
[INAUDIBLE] are not able to speak to express. How painful that situation is..
[INAUDIBLE] If I am at least able to improve that life even 1% I will feel more [INAUDIBLE] I was happy
and I was satisfied. At least empower one person. I brought impact in their life.
I just empower the life even one person, I'll be more than happy.
So I just came back to my home and keep on thinking that what kind of so that they can do everything like normal humans.
I just kept thinking and thinking and thinking.
And I finally come to the conclusion that to do something I should figure out what's the common thing to do in a normal
human and a disabled person. I found that brain is common. Only to thinking to other things is not that user friendly.
Everything has a point to the person who will be using that invention..
[INAUDIBLE] multiple things is very difficult because what we think exactly we don't act.
I want to move my hand in this way. Think to move the hand in this way and I command my hand to move in this way.
[INAUDIBLE] So that is the control.
So next interesting thing that I found which is common and which is not parallelized.
Which is common that is breathing. [INAUDIBLE] becomes uncommon like paralysis in a normal human.
All the breathing is not [INAUDIBLE] which is common and which is [INAUDIBLE] properly.
With a normal human and a disabled person. And [INAUDIBLE] control normal breathing.
[INAUDIBLE] Model or technology concern. It's small gadget which converts breathing [INAUDIBLE] to magnetic impulse.
Speaker 2: And it designed in such a way that this acts as a single switch to multiple switch options.
Again we also [INAUDIBLE] of [INAUDIBLE] scrolling. That the future to make forward, left, right movement..
Or to operate electrical appliances. Or to text message..
Which option the person wants to activate [NOISE] [INAUDIBLE] It will just wait for two seconds [INAUDIBLE] to change,
which stops only once [NOISE] activate. Again [SOUND] option will deactivate and again option will keep on scrolling.
So I tried to make that in a simplified way.
You notice it's not something to make something complicated circuit or something complicated.
It's all about how simply we're able to solve that problem. The incumbent problem.
So a simplified solution is always a great innovation, what I feel.
So in this way, in this version of enabler,
happened that the disabled person with a physically assistive device for the disabled person to empower them to do many
activities like humans do. Like navigating a wheelchair.
Like operating all the electrical appliances, texting messages in a specially designed cell phone,
and so many other activities.
Speaker 1: And that was your first invention?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: There it started.
Speaker 1: What came after?
Speaker 2: After making this I got my second President of India [INAUDIBLE] for this invention.
And from the [INAUDIBLE] and [INAUDIBLE] not everything happened all of a sudden after [INAUDIBLE] magazines, news,
and I was [INAUDIBLE] getting that glory for each and every one. I was like what happened all of a sudden?
I was leading a normal life and how this happened all of a sudden.
But in that glory and then one thing I realized that, this is not for which I'm the universal.
That I realized when I was doing pilot testing on one of the disabled person.
When the disabled person was doing the pilot testing of a device. He just I just how would I had instructed to do.
I just gave a five minute training. And he just [INAUDIBLE] wheelchair forward then right and stopped.
Then he changed options and activated the bulb. I saw the tears falling from his eyes.
Speaker 1: It worked.
Speaker 2: And I realized that that was not tears of sorrow, that was tears of joy.
Looking I started also my, so my eyes also tears came open. I feel that's the real success which I am achieving.
This is the real success.
Finally the you know what's being used by the target person for which for whom I have developed that innovation.
So if I'm able to empower one disabled person life then my purpose of making [INAUDIBLE] is fulfilled.
If I can empower one person then I can empower millions [INAUDIBLE] then yeah then [INAUDIBLE]
we can I mean push this product to the market either we can license to any company.
[INAUDIBLE] we realize that [INAUDIBLE]
medical device so it's better that we should license this invention to any [INAUDIBLE]
that can properly manufacture it at that finished product label.
They can manufacture in that label, so that a disabled person can get the maximum benefit out of it.
So thought it's better that we should license to any metacompany. And we are in position to do that.
Because do commerce like this in because it is going to empower millions of disabled people's life.
So it's better we're already established in this biotechnology
and types of medical technology industries are in this field.
Because at [INAUDIBLE] great level I thought that these people can make it global public and to in that level,
with that financing, with that I mentioned with that vision they can just make it reach to that global level.
And second because as of now we are focusing on some other innovation. On variable.
And also it's better not to focus on multiple areas, just to focus on one area where we can give our best.
So I thought there are many, many people who can their best in this area. Big industries for that.
So in this way we are thinking to get a global impact.
Speaker 1: That's quite a thing for a 24 year old.
Speaker 2: Well yeah, what I thought when I was 16 years old. [LAUGH] Yeah.
Speaker 1: And why do you think it's so unique what you are doing?
Speaker 2: See because I didn't [INAUDIBLE] find exact of the preferred solution to solve that [INAUDIBLE] programs.
For everything there is a solution but there is not a simplified solution.
[INAUDIBLE] we have that streaks [INAUDIBLE] or the joystick wheelchair. That's inventions that are there.
But I feel that whether it is exactly serving the problem.
None of them can serve 100% problem but how much [INAUDIBLE] and probability. Of solving the problem that matters.
And how much percent of the problem is being solved that matters.
If there's an innovation which solves 80% of the problem, if I making a [INAUDIBLE]
90% of the problem then that in [INAUDIBLE] should have it.
And when [INAUDIBLE] gives us something internet and all Many other ways, like, I said, we do this macro-survey.
Whether it [INAUDIBLE] is there or not, or any particular solution is there or not.
If I find that there is no such particular solution, or a great solution,
or the perfect solution for any of the encountered problem,
then I feel that I We know something had to be done either by evaluation to the existing universals
or to create a new universal if it is not there.
Speaker 1: So did you feel aware of those that you are now going to produce?
Is this solution for an Indian and it's for that reason that it works?
Speaker 2: Or is it Yeah, it's started first because of looking into Indian problem.
But finally, I found that it's not only an Indian disability problem.
If you say, global record that US is in the number one percent and can [INAUDIBLE] number of everyday and every year.
Second comes Brazil and third comes India.
But in the increasing number of everyday as for the current scenario then India comes number one.
I don't know what happens in two or three of the [INAUDIBLE] is [INAUDIBLE]
and there is no partner in solution of [INAUDIBLE] just put the [INAUDIBLE] on that.
The cops, police, everyone is working at a great level but the thing is that somewhere, something is missing.
Although there are some solutions like taser guns, pepper spray.
But that's not going to because then I would try to understand the psychology of human way.
I mean people are not using the existing universes of products which is there in the market One thing that is dropping
them to use that is a style shipment in there. Not that, those are not fashionable.
Like if there were people spend the thing then why the people express that way? Why who is going to write them?
And it happens all additionally energy system.
So Psychology creates a problem that that confidence [INAUDIBLE] nothing is going to happen.
You just take the example of helmet.
[INAUDIBLE] but to save them from getting [INAUDIBLE] then that's why they are wearing helmets..
We are not [INAUDIBLE] No one things for the worst.
Which is going to happen, so they are just highly confident that nothing's going to happen
and that's where they don't use people's [INAUDIBLE] or whatever the possible [INAUDIBLE]
have been done to the [INAUDIBLE] and second [INAUDIBLE] any kind of [INAUDIBLE] not fashionable..
And [INAUDIBLE] that those are not variable.
[INAUDIBLE] can be used against us. And then can [INAUDIBLE] Same for the [INAUDIBLE] and any other gadgets.
So last we found that cannot be snatched. But snatching more difficult.
I understand that it can be snatched but it will be difficult than to snatch something which you hold,
which is not wearable. Wearable things [INAUDIBLE] difficult to snatch.?
Now we thought that what have we done with [INAUDIBLE] It will be difficult to snatch as well.
Because obviously we have to compare between a man and a woman man is more physically strong.
And confidence wise [INAUDIBLE] but we have to empower the women or girls.
By giving some value in the problem gadget or something.
So we thought that let's improve on small [INAUDIBLE] which one or two second [INAUDIBLE]
200 degrees celsius which is quite enough to burn someone's hand if someone tries to grab the gadget.
Or grab Any part of the hand or somewhere.
The gull can at least make that gadget contact with any part of the screen and get a severe pain.
It will change the mood or mindset of the attacker.
It will get a fear and panic in the attacker that he should not further attack. That should be used at the last moment.
Before that, we have included a panic button.
Just press panic button, like a siren will get activated which is around 180-200 decibel sound,
which is equal to the ambulance and the police siren.
It can be kept in the lady's purse and it will create a havoc in the environment and it will create a hear in the
Speaker 2: [INAUDIBLE] attacker.
And at the same time [INAUDIBLE] will go to the registered numbers and [INAUDIBLE] will go and [INAUDIBLE].
nearest [INAUDIBLE] And in this way this [INAUDIBLE] assessment is [INAUDIBLE]
But we know that only just using this protein [INAUDIBLE] wearable is not going to track the [INAUDIBLE] [INAUDIBLE]
customers or the [INAUDIBLE] title [INAUDIBLE] for whom this gadgets we are developing.
For woman, for girls, fashion is a statement, so, in overall we designed it as a smart safety,
smart safety fitness watch. Yes. And finally we included the fitness features and all like the form of a digital watch.
A digital watch that incorporates all the personal features and a hidden [INAUDIBLE] features..
So people will wear as a style statement [INAUDIBLE] if any kind of [INAUDIBLE]
So we are pushing this product in that way in the global market.
Speaker 1: It's like you found almost a niche in the market.
You found a corner in the market that hasn't been covered by others.
Speaker 2: Yes. That's it.
Speaker 1: Has it not been?
Speaker 2: There are fitness was, some better and better and fitness was in the globe.
There are many features, but all in the one available is not available. See, everything is there.
They're like When you make food, you have vegetables and all. But this you make is innovative.
So how you collect the specialty vegetables and all, and how we make it food, that matters.
Finally, how you use the and the sauce, people. Spices and all.
That matters how wonderful and how great you make the food. Because every [INAUDIBLE] everywhere.
So same in case of this gadgets and all. So I will part it into individual features.
Those features will be available everywhere.
But how inadvertently you design how it will consume low power, how effectively it will work,
how much it is user friendly. That matters so this is the one we look we innovate to make it a user friendly solution.
How I mean the target customer like the women and girls can properly use this gadget.
So it's kind of smooth all in one. [INAUDIBLE] design fitness watch with certain features all in one.
Variable is I didn't find anywhere. That's why we developed this gadget.
Speaker 1: And where did you get your knowledge from?
Speaker 2: It's all about [INAUDIBLE] and I am [INAUDIBLE] the work.
I found a problem, and then I tried to identify a proper solution to this.
[INAUDIBLE] I saw that as a problem, this is the encountered problem.
And to this innovation, I accredited it to this innovation. This problem is going to solve.
This is just an idea a raw concept, a raw idea. This is going to put a solution to the problem..
Then we do a market survey.
Solve the [INAUDIBLE] but we found that there are not such great variables
or not such great gadgets which can actually solve the problem.
Then we thought that we have to finally [INAUDIBLE] something. Now I cannot do each and every thing.
It's obvious because I have knowledge in innovation and all, but I have the knowledge and technology as well.
But by doing everything all on our own is very, very difficult. So I develop a prototype.
But to make it a product, that takes teamwork. So now I generalize the work.
But one thing in me that I know, I have a knowledge of which work has to be done at which place.
Who are the right people, who are the people who can do it effectively. What they have that available currently.
I have that knowledge. Due to my experience or due to my exposure of the world. Maybe that [INAUDIBLE] But due to this..
Speaker 1: [INAUDIBLE] It's on again [LAUGH] You should show them. Find a solution for [INAUDIBLE] [LAUGH]
Speaker 2: Yeah..
Speaker 3: Finding the people [LAUGH]
Speaker 2: Yeah so yeah so yeah I was in that so finally. I told her who are the right people, we're very available.
Who will be able to do a particular thing effectively. Like someone will be doing a great design.
So I found it, tried to create a team, all the great designers, innovative designers, who can attest to a.
So I found to create a team. To create talented and like-minded team around the globe.
Then I keep on challenging the things. Which part goes with who can do in a better way?
Then I try to combine everything to form, including my ideas and innovation
and whatever I can implement if I have done this.
And everyone would do this [INAUDIBLE] and combine to make it one product. So that finally it can create impact.
Speaker 1: And that's what you're saying is that you have a lot of ideas, a lot of inventions you make?
You take one out and commercialize it. But when you look at the other inventions what kind of ideas?
Started when you were 16 a part of the wheelchair.
Speaker 2: That time I realized that to push everything [INAUDIBLE] any of the big companies like Apple,
like Microsoft. You see they came to market with one product. Find the one product that can become a hit.
Success and then it came with other products. Even with that one product they keep updating that one product..
[INAUDIBLE] Apple or Microsoft or [INAUDIBLE] They have one product.
They're focusing to the one product and those are successful focus to the one product.
And they're the one who's creating millions and millions of impact.
So I was particular that if I want to try to impact at the global level I should focus to the one product.
If that is [INAUDIBLE] then I should go to the other product. I would like to go with my [INAUDIBLE] licensing.
To any of the company I can license the innovations, and [INAUDIBLE] I'll do.
It will license by any of the [INAUDIBLE]
organizations that we can add some in every unit we can add some value to that product and they can.
Or they will also add value to the product
and we can jointly we can do the commercialization in the joint collaboration for the commercialization
or by licensing completely to the third-party organization.
In this way other innovations can get into the market and that would create impact.
I would think that each and every innovation from my organization
or from my company I'm going to push is very difficult. And that is everything will not get disturbed.
Speaker 1: I understand that, but that's lots of people have these ideas.
Why is it that you were awarded so many awards.
Speaker 2: The way I visualize and imagine a particular program and I found a effective solution for that.
It's all about how effectively the innovation is going to solve the problem, and how simplified the innovation is.
How innovative the idea is. If you take everything into consideration that's where it's been by the president of India..
[INAUDIBLE] What have I got so far? So that [INAUDIBLE] matters..
I could have done in a more manner. It's all about [INAUDIBLE] [INAUDIBLE]
Speaker 1: That's why you were awarded.
Speaker 2: Yeah, you could say that.
Speaker 1: And do you agree with that? That you were awarded?
Speaker 2: Yeah, because first thing, on the big night I was thinking that there are many more great innovators,
there are many more innovations, gadgets which are far complicated than my innovations. But why I got awarded?
And obviously the people who give the award out, that win a lot of talented jury members and all would have sit
and thought that whom they should [INAUDIBLE] choose me.
And obviously they represent something that [INAUDIBLE] my innovations.
Something greatness they have found in that innovation.
Then [INAUDIBLE] from them are from somewhere I came to know that, it's [INAUDIBLE].
because how simply program has been solved.
And those innovations these are the innovations that can revolutionize the current scenario.
And it's not about always a complicated opposite, all levels just simplifying.
Speaker 1: And can you tell me, explain a bit more of the innovations you were awarded for.
You have the wheelchair, you have the watch. Other innovations or inventions you?
Speaker 2: Yeah. Well we have also designed a low-cost electricity system like a [INAUDIBLE] with a great efficiency.
[INAUDIBLE] so yeah but what we have [INAUDIBLE] only if you [INAUDIBLE] has to be done.
[INAUDIBLE] and you can get around 12 to 15 hours electricity.
So that innovativeness we did is that talent we have work on by making that innovation. That's a action which we did.
So for such kind of a gadget now there are many better gadgets like during those days since five to six or several.
We did a gadget where we can open all the computer and laptop applications without using a keyboard and mouse.
The keyboard and mouse we transfer to a gadget.
Just like we just act everything in the air and that will get resulted on the computer screen.
Like I would click here, that would get clicked. I will like I can type here. Everything I can do so.
[INAUDIBLE] great revolutionary invention but now there are a lot many since came.
So in this way there a lot of innovations [INAUDIBLE] because we know that driverless cars are [INAUDIBLE] cost
and design it's one. If people want some more designs of the car or something they cannot get a driverless.
To get a driverless car they have to buy that particular car.
And it is difficult that the vision is to reduce road accidents. Its vision is to reduce traffic jams and all.
So, each and every vehicle has to be driverless. If not, only one who can get it's not possible.
Everyone can afford a driverless car.
Everyone cannot that all together will not sell their old car to get the driverless car.
So you have to think for each and every one.
So like I told her, keep committees then, which can be implemented each and every vehicle, even a low-cost vehicle,
even someone is using a low-cost vehicle.
And the kit can implement from a low-cost vehicle to a vehicle who vehicle that is more than millions.
And those vehicles were converted to a driverless.
Ensure making a driverless car minor to make a driverless kit and instruct, make it a driverless one.
So that is where the global story, the mobility industries.
Speaker 1: And that's and what's your role in that?
Speaker 2: Yeah we have designed the kit.
So we are looking that we can license to any team automobile industry so that they can get into the market.
We don't want to commercialize this innovation.
Speaker 1: And what makes it Indian what you're doing? It's so specific that.
Speaker 2: Yeah because see in India traffic jams and [INAUDIBLE] is more as compared to the other developed countries.
Because here the traffic management is gradually getting proper but [INAUDIBLE]
scenario you can see the traffic jams and all is a matter of concern.
So, to solve that I feel that [INAUDIBLE] vehicle.
Speaker 1: So is what you see in your daily life, [INAUDIBLE] is you're trying to solve.
Speaker 2: Sure, what I am seeing. But primarily when I'm inventing something, I'm looking at the global aspect..
How globally it [INAUDIBLE] And it always start from one place.
So as being an Indian, I'm looking at how fast I will [INAUDIBLE] to impact in India.
Then the same thing I can replicate to create impact around the globe.
Because everyone is a human being and I believe that humanity matters.
Speaker 1: And in what way is meditation helping you to find solution?
Speaker 2: Yes because I'm looking beyond my imagination, beyond that level that is going to solve the problem.
It's not in my mind that it won't work.
So that comes, that extra, that power is required to think different, think unique.
So I feel that because of that, I'm able to think beyond my imagination, beyond that capacity.,
May be different from people [INAUDIBLE] but I feel that helps me, that drives me to deliver something, really..
Speaker 1: And what's happening when you're meditating? Can you explain me what's happening in your head then?
Speaker 2: See I am able to visualize, I will be able to visualize my vision.
Our vision is to impact, to empower 50 million users worldwide in the next five years.
So I'm able to visualize that, how we are going. If we are going in right direction or wrong, what we should do next.
I'm able to see that. In the form of a dream or in the form of a video. What do I see when I am closing my eyes.
I'm able to see that, ideas. What [INAUDIBLE] show now, we are going in this direction.
Or there is some problem and we should shift to this direction. Or we should do this to create more impact.
So I'm able to scan that five-year vision.
What I have done now, where we are standing, what we have to do more to stand, at this position.
So how this can multiply through that impact we're created from millions to billions.
So how it can, i just, we are able to visualize that and we strictly focused to our vision.
And we assume that if will,
I think that vision in the next five years we will even active in the if you were able to at least 50% of our.
In the next five years, that has been it will multiply to billions in next five or next 10 to 15 years billions
or automatically. Through mouth publicity or through the noise, which will be created.
It will automatically get multiplied. So we don't need to then focus to impact billions.
If we can impact millions, then automatically it will multiply to billions.
Speaker 1: Where you say visualize, what happens in your head? Can you explain me the different steps?
Speaker 2: Yeah three.
Speaker 1: For these three hours of medication..
Speaker 2: Actually in this [INAUDIBLE] we have chakras.
We can say crown [INAUDIBLE] in English there is [INAUDIBLE] throat, this is to the heart,
so you are energized as you can say. All these when you some there's some extra energy in the universe.
So when you meditate, when you use like I actually I'll do the advance which is mantra healing.
Reykian mantra healing I do generally. So in that I just transfer the cosmic energy to my body..
And in that process obviously that energy enters through here to [INAUDIBLE] And then it's [INAUDIBLE]
to the outer environment. So that enters [INAUDIBLE] body. Then there is the effect to the environment.
So that energy helps you to gain that strength and that confidence that overall development you get..
You get a power to [INAUDIBLE] That is most important. The people that are successful at [INAUDIBLE] right thing.
So that things you will feel that you are able to get that confidence that yes this is the right decision you are
taking. This is a right time to do this work.
This type of development I feel that it happens [INAUDIBLE] and it will hit you
and the energy will hit you into the body. Yes you will feel that hit if you are doing it properly.
Speaker 1: And it's three hours a day.
Speaker 2: I do one for five hours you can say.
Speaker 1: Five hours?
Speaker 2: Not five hours, two hours thirty minutes.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 2: 2.5 hours.
Speaker 1: And then you're completely heated?.
Speaker 2: Yeah completely heated and that aggression and energy has created [INAUDIBLE] If I plan this,
I will be able to achieve this. I don't know, I've got that extra boost, you can say.
To move that with that force to achieve that vision.
Every day I'm doing something that my vision is getting achieved everyday.
Everyday I am just putting a drop of that to fulfill that vision.
Speaker 1: And when you could explain that vision that you have. What is it?
The vision you have, where are you in five, ten years?
Speaker 2: Yeah in the next five years, we are just visualizing to impact 50 million users in the next five years.
And to achieve the 50 million users obviously and that's who [INAUDIBLE] products.
So we are now making a product in such a way that millions of people are going to buy this product.
They would like to feel [INAUDIBLE]
special by which it will make them feel for awhile that special if they wear this device, so to make them that feel.
So we're just trying to create that [INAUDIBLE] in such a way that people will just love to get this product.
Will feel special at getting this product.
So we are doing that so and we are [INAUDIBLE] in a couple of months we will do this
and we will just put this product to the market.
And then it will just multiply to where from thousands to millions then millions you keep on increasing.
But yes the graph will be like this like this ups and downs will come, be we'll show [INAUDIBLE]
that if we get some critiques we'll keep on doing value to that and that we're doing through pilot testings.
We're doing a lot of pilot testings, a lot of trials, and what the critiques are getting we're just improving that..
We're improving our features but we are just besides [INAUDIBLE] Will do it fashionable design
and what we will do we will put that in front of the public and public will present that.
Speaker 1: You were 16 eight years ago. So you have now an eight year, you have 25 people working with you?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Where did you make your money off the last eight years?
Speaker 2: Obviously our products are not yet launching into market
but we have started creating a noise of the product, that this is going to be launching to market.
But doing a lot of pilot testing, trials on the people.
The money we are getting is through [INAUDIBLE] business which is our secondary business..
But let me kind of say of our organization.
So we'll do something [INAUDIBLE] projects for industries for corporates, for governments,
and through this becomes one of the revenue source for company as of the present..
And second it creates an experience to a team and to make them [INAUDIBLE] diversify knowledge [INAUDIBLE]
And we take such projects that would help us make our products better. We don't do every kind of confidential business.
We are very focused, even if we are doing a confidential business,
we are focused on which kind of innovations we would take from our clients.
We take those products which would help our team get experience so that they can do in our products.
Speaker 1: And what kind of [INAUDIBLE] it's very general.
Speaker 2: We are into IOT automation and we are [INAUDIBLE] to these areas, automation, IOT solutions.
Although there are products, many things happen but we are [INAUDIBLE] to this, if any of the product or [INAUDIBLE]
that has any of this sectors like mechanics and all, we just outsource it to some other organization
or to other collaborated partners.
Speaker 1: And looking at yourself as a person, six years, you were first awarded at 17, I think?
Speaker 2: At my 16.
Speaker 1: At 16, you were awarded?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: And then what kind of awards you built afterwards till.
Speaker 2: So like inter level I got the NASA I know so many it happened all of a sudden.
Because when our [INAUDIBLE] automatically obviously you will get that boost, natural boost,
or such innovations so you will be rewarded next and next.,
So you got to at least express when you got [INAUDIBLE] so you learn that see [INAUDIBLE] after so many failures..
[INAUDIBLE] and fail means [INAUDIBLE] learning. So that's also [INAUDIBLE] You use a fail first to achieve something.
So you learn through fail and you also learn by achieving that, so you are particular what to do and what not to do.
Speaker 1: So what is it that you will not do [INAUDIBLE]
Speaker 2: I command both then when I think of version, [INAUDIBLE] other things.
When I'm doing this [INAUDIBLE] what should I not do and what should I do?
And by which [INAUDIBLE] thought what to do and what not do. All the [INAUDIBLE] what I am doing.
I can go hours in various organizations and [INAUDIBLE]
Speaker 1: And would you sum up briefly, what kind of innovations and inventions you did?
Can you tell me several things.
Speaker 2: [LAUGH] [INAUDIBLE] Very long. Okay fine one is the in a you can see the of which I just described.
One is the low cluster. I mean, one kit, one accidental technology.
Because in the is far from the mountains, because of the night with the roads are not visible [INAUDIBLE]
for people from the mountain.
So that now would just design a kit that can be implemented in a vehicle by which the vehicle stopping there is no
place to move. If there is a hole, or there's a pit. There is road end.
If there is no road cause the vehicle will stop and then it will slightly move back and put the brake.
Speaker 1: And.
Speaker 2: Yes, sure, and one's that low cost product for the villagers and for the rural empowerment,
we did that device, that gate which can provide electricity to the villagers at a very affordable price.
Then we did your driver less kit which can implement in a vehicle to, I mean to make the completely driver less car.
Yeah, then we designed a kit which can be implemented in any of the home.
Whenever you will be inside the home, inside the room, there will be the electrical appliances will be active.
Whenever you leave the room, the electricity will automatically go off,
because generally we forget to switch off the device and all.
So whenever you are in the lighting should be there, whenever you are not there, the lighting should be off.
At a very low cost, affordable price. Then,
Speaker 2: Then some universals, which is not Exactly. I mean useful for the public data.
[INAUDIBLE] For instance for a [INAUDIBLE] since we did some.
These are the innovations which [INAUDIBLE] something [INAUDIBLE]
which is going to create interest in the youth-first technology towards innovations.
If we don't have [INAUDIBLE] has an indirect benefit. For entertainment purpose, for educational purpose.
And during my seminars where I am the guest speaker in colleges or in corporations
or schools I used to display such gadgets. And creates interest in the youth towards technology.
So the [INAUDIBLE] that will be operated from hand gestures. Whether I will move my hand or don't really move.
And [INAUDIBLE] designed it. I [INAUDIBLE] [INAUDIBLE] hard hard work. Then the ripples will get activate.
And like the hand and the chest will get activate.
So these are some of the innovations that create interest in youth because they can connect with,
they're really super heroes. That they have seen this super heroes in a television, in a movie.
But they know that that's animated. When they see that thing in a real form, in a form of universal.
So they think that the innovation is so wonderful, so beautiful.
So entirely that field you know so this technology is really interesting.
So they are then driven by passion towards networks and technology universal economy.
Speaker 1: That when I hear these examples, which are very nice, but I also think immediately but I've seen that there,
I've seen it in the US. I've seen it in Europe.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: I've seen it. So why don't they import that in India instead of waiting for your innovations to be made?
Speaker 2: See, there might be something [INAUDIBLE] better than me. [INAUDIBLE] better than which I have done.
But it's all about to find a test. To find a test in the customer, offer that to your customer.
When you do innovation you find, who are targeted customer, what are targeted area.
I will give an example and from that example you will find answer. Both took the example of Amazon and.
They both are the great companies. And Amazon is obviously here and flip [INAUDIBLE] and everyone knows that.
Only one thing you can find in India there is a lot of companies like this.
Amazon, there is, so in India Amazon already [INAUDIBLE] but there's some in India that [INAUDIBLE] there is SnapDeal,
there are many e-commerce companies. [INAUDIBLE] was the one who aggressively captured the Indian market first.
And why? Because of the one simplified feature that improved it. Amazon is far much better and big than Flipkart.
But Flipkart wins in capturing the Indian market.
Because the person, the cofounder, the owner of the Flipkart is Indian,
and he thought that what that innovative feature can be done.
That can add a test in the [INAUDIBLE] so that can add [INAUDIBLE] so the people would like to eat that food...
And what you do he just included [INAUDIBLE] Which Amazon included [INAUDIBLE] but that time hit the [INAUDIBLE]
And people aggressively followed FlipKart.
Because in Indians people don't generally trust on e-commerce if they are passed then the letter get the products.
In India feel that hand to hand. Give the product, they take the money.
So that one filter that created relatively, he get there completely the Indian market.
So the question was to hire the from nine thousand one-th of the I am looking into that.
I am adding such features which is, for whom I am targeting the area of the customers, I mean, my target customers,
in a particular area, to whom I am targeting, I am very focused at, these are the target customers whom I am focusing..
Indians, let's say.
If I'm looking into US I will do some changes in the features.
If I look in the Saudi, Arab countries, I do some changes in the features..
So for different place, in Hindi there is a statement like, [FOREIGN]
Speaker 2: New place, new people, so you have to act accordingly as per their taste and all.
You have to modify so, I mean, new place, there will be new people.
So, I mean, in say, one product which will be liked by Indian may not be liked by British,
also may not be liked by people in US. The product which will be liked by US, may not be liked by Indians.
So the product you have to keep on changing small minor things you have to do if you are changing from target custom
variable. Tending the direction of your customers. When you use Indian, ABC should be a filter.
When it's US it should be BCD. If it is British house it maybe DEF. So in that way.
So if I'm focusing India, so if Indians are not focusing on the I'd rather then focus on this for them.
Because I found that this ABC is going to attract them to create interest in them. It's as simple as it is.
Speaker 1: So the uniqueness is also that you were in this hospital looking at this man, trying,
needing a wheelchair that he could move himself.
Speaker 2: Yes, himself, but main thing they should be affordable.
If they import a wheelchair that could be cost more than two or three or half a millions.
At least they know that this wheelchair which I have developed is low cost, is affordable.
Even I give flexible options. I give flexible options like don't have [INAUDIBLE] wheelchair.
When you donate a wheelchair you can get the kit at the price of 15 to 20,000 rupees.
Can get this kit, you can sit and [INAUDIBLE] and you can operate electrical appliances, you can text messages.
If you want the mobility of some, we can [INAUDIBLE] local [INAUDIBLE] for you.
[INAUDIBLE] for you and your customers [INAUDIBLE] and we can implement [INAUDIBLE] in the wheelchair.
So providing that special option to the target customer makes them feel special?
and they choose you rather than choosing any other. Why they will invest [INAUDIBLE]
Speaker 2: I mean more money if they're getting the special thing [INAUDIBLE]
so I know that what exactly is going to attract Indian customers.
Speaker 1: And how many wheelchair owners or people that are disabled are using your kit?
Speaker 2: Currently there will be more than twenty, i can say will be, but in a formal pilot testing,
because this is not a product which we are commercializing at our own brand.
So, during the pilot testings and through some tie-up organisations.
I mean, they just develop some of the units and we helped them in developing those and kits units
and it was been [INAUDIBLE] by many of the users. Maybe to at the hospitals in this way.
But officially we're not commercializing this.
We are [INAUDIBLE] with the companies so that they can commercialize in a better way.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's not commercialized yet.
Speaker 2: Yes.
Speaker 1: No and when you look around the globe, who are your heroes?
Who would, when you envision somebody that you would like to be can you think of one.
Speaker 2: Every successful people and every unsuccessful people are my heroes.
From successful people I learn what to do and from every unsuccessful people I learn what not to do. [INAUDIBLE]
Speaker 2: Like I said [INAUDIBLE] Steve Jobs. Each one of them, like Elon Musk, these people have massively done that.
I learned everything [INAUDIBLE] I learned what other things make mistakes and [INAUDIBLE] to reach that level.
From there I learned that what I should not do and what I should do.
So that I can reach that [INAUDIBLE] at our [INAUDIBLE] you feel that I am [INAUDIBLE]
at a young age because of that I try to learn from other's experience.
By what they have down which they got a downfall, what they have done got an achievement.
Like if you take the example of Elon Musk,
like PayPal whatever he has earned like around $150 million he earned through PayPal,
he invested into completely into Tesla Motors and SpaceX. We don't know why he did.
He even didn't establish single penny. I mean he borrowed.
In those days, he was borrowing from his friends and he was staying in a rented house.
I don't know [INAUDIBLE] did what. But I think he was more focused to the vision.
When you don't want [INAUDIBLE] you can invest that [INAUDIBLE] he did that.
He was completely involved in fulfilling his vision. So for many [INAUDIBLE] has done is right.
Speaker 1: And when you put it on yourself. What makes you a visionary for others who think?
Speaker 2: See, I notice every human can tend to think they should have a luxurious life, or a royal life.
He should have a bungalow, he should have a car, he should have luxurious vehicles. He should lead a royal lifestyle.
Every human being wants that. But there are some people that to achieve that, they just focus on that.
How are we going to achieve that, how we are going to achieve a big house, how will drive our dream car,
or how we will have a lot of bank balance, they focus on that.
There are some people, like, I also want that kind of life. But I'm not focusing to do that.
I know that if I should focus to my vision, everything will come, everything will put in my place.
So everything will be put in the place.
I don't need to focus how much my bank balance, whether I have my dream house or not, or whether I have a mansion
or not, do I have a dream car or not. I don't need to focus there.
I know that all this all this dreams will be fulfilled if I fulfill my vision. If I stick to my vision.
Everything will get put in my bag. So this all will be put in my list. So I just stick to the vision.
I know that I can accept that by focusing on the vision. So, if I from the vision, everything will go, go away.
And but the real happiness that I'm going to get is when vision is fulfilled.
If I find and someone says, users changed my life, changed my life.
That is real, my achievement, rather than the of this and this, house or dream, that is my dream house or dream car.
I can hear a that this has reality saved my life. Thank you so much.
If I hear this small statement from any of my users, I am more than happy.
Speaker 1: And I understand that, but then still, why are you, in the eyes of other people, a visionary?
Speaker 2: Because I stick to my vision. Every time the activities I do that gives value to the vision.
And what [INAUDIBLE] I do I step every day I step one ladder to reach the destination of the vision
and people can see if I'm doing that that will be. Seen by others and that's why they feel that I am visionary.
Speaker 1: So you will be the next Elon Musk, probably.
Speaker 2: Yeah, why not? I'd love to.
Speaker 1: First of all, you wanted to tell something about your big example.
Speaker 2: Yeah first you asked, whether I wanted to be the next Elon Musk.
I will say yes, I want to be the next Elon Musk of India. I can say because Elon Musk is a really great entrepeneur.
And first I will be myself, I will be who's similar to next Elon Musk of India.
So obviously with my uniqueness, with my some innovative mind and entrepreneurial mind obviously.
If I would have fulfilled that vision,
I would have been able to I think the vision if I had been able to impact millions of life, billions of life
and obviously to reach that percentage is will be not a big deal.
Speaker 1: And what is your vision?
Speaker 2: Yeah, just what I just mentioned before.
I like to empower 15 million users worldwide in the next five years.
Then, and obviously to raise a billion will be very easier if that vision is active in the next five years.
Speaker 1: What kind of problems do you encounter here in India? I suppose it's not all one success story.
Speaker 2: See, if you want to find problems, and you should come to India, I can say.
So there is lot more and we take problems as achievement.
If there is a problem, then that's achievement because there is a lot many things that we can learn
and a lot many things we can explore. And where we can use our mind to develop something which can solve that problem.
And that problem may be directly and indirectly will be finished by the other parts of the world as well.
So that can greater impact in that areas as well.
So anything that is, in modern India it's not only solving the problems of Indian politics,
it's also solving the problems of the global people as well.
Speaker 1: So you see Indian problems and try to find solutions for that?
Speaker 2: Exactly, exactly.
Speaker 1: And the question whether what makes what you invent more unique than what already exists in the world?
Speaker 2: [INAUDIBLE] how very inadvertently I have done any invention.
It happens finally but that depends to make it more user-friendly. I don't look to make it user-friendly.
If something that is similar to the existing innovation, if my innovation has some extra one features,
I would like to market that innovation.
I would like to present innovation to the market whether it's from my organization company
or whether through organization or whether it's in the collaboration with other organizations or companies.
So if there, by evaluating that one feature in a resident industry, you're really creating impact.
And I would like to push that. If we, to make it more user-friendly, then we can get a great computer data system.
So it happens when I'm focusing to make it user-friendly. It becomes innovation.
Speaker 1: I, for this series we filmed in the most modern elapse you can imagine.
The unique, yesterday in the fap lab I have to admit it was not the most modern.
How is it that fap lab that come the newest innovation?
Speaker 2: Yeah, there's type of place where allow other makers to privilege lab.
We just provide privilege and access to that lab.
They can access the lab, the they can do something to prototypes and products.
Like yesterday you filmed that and you saw that how there are some different methods.
So we're doing some different things.
So we just try to create that ecosystem where the other methods and [INAUDIBLE] will come and open a model.
Like open work space so people can do team.
They will do they will do but finally they will do something that is going to create an impact.
So that's a will be provided at a young age, at a year, and then they will get impact at such,
when they will come to at least In their 30s or 40s.
So if they will keep struggling till their 30s or 40s then obviously, if they will utilize that time
and effort in creating that space, then they will start working and it will consume a lot of time.
Efficiency will decrease.
So now that these guys Only to give effort to, I mean, to create a vast space, which we have already created.
So there's a need to execute their ideas into products, and push to the market.
We also help project ecosystem, that manufacturing peak ecosystem, that talent ecosystem, Getting tie ups
or collaborate some ecosystems by which that can sort of get into market at earliest as possible.
Speaker 1: So is that good? The television experience you had??
So it is good to have a bit of a clumsy kind of lab because there you can discover and invent. Is that [CROSSTALK]
Speaker 2: And obviously, when there are more and more, if you provide space to other makers
and innovators will come other makers and innovators, too. Worker and under one umbrella.
Now with that ecosystem where we can discuss each other, we can create critics each other
and finally a best strategy will come out of that. Only you think to develop and a team will think to develop.
So obviously the team is going to create the impact.
Speaker 1: It's like you created a place where you can research the television.
Speaker 2: Yes.
Speaker 1: Something like that, yeah. When I hear you, you- [INAUDIBLE]
Speaker 1: Did you have your vest open or closed?
Speaker 2: Closed, closed, so this closed, closed. So it was open?
Speaker 1: It was opened.
Speaker 2: Opened, yeah. Yeah.
Speaker 1: I should open it?
Speaker 2: Yeah. Please, as is was. [INAUDIBLE]
Speaker 1: No. We don't have to do it again, but I mean it's just, from now on it's okay. It's okay. No no no.
Keep it open.
Speaker 2: Sorry sorry. I didn't know.,
Speaker 1: No, that's our responsibility. Yeah.
So when you talk, you talk like a person with a lot of experience, but you're only 24 years old.
Speaker 2: But I have seven years experience in the field of universal and entrepreneurial.
Although I Officially, we have incorporated our company, InThinks, our startup I can say.
Our startup InThinks, Innovators and Thinkers, InThinks. And our slogan is empowering future.
So we have recently incorporated last year, but before officially incorporating, we started a journey.
And through that journey, we have learned a lot of Struggles and all up downs so that gives us experience.
And by [INAUDIBLE] to the global network so that creates a lot of experience to us and still we are learners.
[INAUDIBLE]
we will keep the learning attitude whenever possible from our top leaders to the Failures to even from a child.
If I'm able to learn something [INAUDIBLE] more privileged I am getting a chance to learn.
If I'm interacting with kids they are learning from me and I am learning from them.
[INAUDIBLE] and that's where I think we are progressing on the right direction.
Speaker 1: And are you focused on yourself not on the we form but the I form.
What did you learn personally from the last as you are still quite young.
When you started 16 was your first invention, what did you, what makes you so successful?
Speaker 2: See I just follow my passion, first my passion was this technology so I am just following my passion.
And [INAUDIBLE] to a profession.
And I believe a person is transforming his passion to a profession then [INAUDIBLE]
because they're following their heart. Money comes along the way to the journey.
So that is [INAUDIBLE] because you might be doing something which you are earning millions.
But if it went for [INAUDIBLE] unless but this person was following the [INAUDIBLE] is [INAUDIBLE]
because he is happier.
This person always want this thing will be haunting him throughout the day, every night through the night [INAUDIBLE]
at least every night he will feel haunting.
Sleeping in his dreams maybe so he has not actually he was interested or he didn't follow his passion.
He might want to be a good writer but he was doing something a nine to five job or he got a better job in.
He's earning Millions every month but he will regret.
Regret will keep on haunting every night that he didn't follow his passion.
Better than to feel regret is you follow your passion and follow your heart.
Speaker 1: That's what you're doing now?
Speaker 2: Yes, in that way I feel that I'm successful. The rest is whether how much you're crediting better.
How much traveling you have done. How much Money you [INAUDIBLE] that will be just a part of the life.
And that is going to happen [INAUDIBLE] time. So we should not focus on that.
We should focus on following your passion. And through a passion how are you [INAUDIBLE] impact.
These two things matters.
Speaker 1: And Can you give me, whats for you, let me see. Whats for you a magic word?
I mean, can you give me a word that you think, wow, this drives me?
Speaker 2: See. Always keep [INAUDIBLE] that's what I learned..
Whether you are in a team or in personal life or professional life.
Expectation should be effectiveness. [INAUDIBLE] whether [INAUDIBLE] because you are going to do that.
There's a difference, I will ask my hand. I will think that I should, if there's a water bottle.
I will ask my hand to get that water bottle for me. So I will go and get, I will come.
Now if I explain that I will ask you go get that water bottle for me.
There are two options whether you will get it or [INAUDIBLE] That options for no if I ask [INAUDIBLE] for me...
But if I ask myself go and get a [INAUDIBLE] for me so that [INAUDIBLE] So it will give [INAUDIBLE]
If you are not able to expertly use then how can you challenge your team to that vision?
So on whom we're expecting is a matter of concern.
Speaker 1: This series, every episode has an archetype. And you are in the archetype, the maker.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Do you agree with that?
Speaker 2: Yeah, I'm a maker first. Because a maker is also an innovator. A maker is also a creator.
So A maker has a free body, is free to do whatever he wants.
He'll try to hack and all, but finally, the result matters when you are an entrepreneur. You are creating impact.
A maker tries to hack anything, destroy anything, create anything,
without focusing that whether it is going to create impact or not. He just tried to create a wow effect out of it.
Which I think when you did the shooting in the fab lab you see how differently we have done some universals and all.
Haphazardly, just to kind of do what you can say. Try to solve a particular problem in that prospective time.
What we didn't because of how that things back.
But finally you have turn it on if we want to make a research to the global people.
So I'm a maker of clash model but finally output on us to create that impact.
By being a make a value not be able to create an impact.
Speaker 1: Okay thank you.
Speaker 2: Kind of with what's now for the schools and that they can afford it. [INAUDIBLE]
Speaker 3: Yeah, could you,
what is the difference in innovating for Indian markets comparing it to other markets world wide, or US markets,
for example? What's the difference?
Speaker 2: Between the innovations?
Speaker 1: What is the difference? In innovating for Indian markets comparing it to other markets?
What makes Indian markets so difficult or special?
Speaker 2: [INAUDIBLE] which should attract that audience that I should get the product.
[INAUDIBLE] That ISO graded products. Everyone, if they want something in their lives, they need a water bottle.
They have some such ideas. Like they should get more quantity, better quality, they should get it at a price.
So Indian has a mindset as let's keep some credit as if they're get attract to any of the product.
Apart from these three, most important is that if anyone is referring, is giving the testimony of that product,
if any of his friend says, you know, that this XYZ water bottle is very awesome, it tastes better.
Speaker 2: Then that Indian is going to get that product which his friend referred.
So that reference, that mouth of publicity matters first. And then they can do the other qualities..
I'm talking about the [INAUDIBLE] not every but of the [INAUDIBLE].
So your product should be sustainable it should get a [INAUDIBLE] It should get into the people's mouth publicity..
It should make them feel that special, so that they can do [INAUDIBLE] In Indians if you talk about iPads,
less people know the [INAUDIBLE] iPads. What many people [INAUDIBLE] that we can afford an iPad.
And sometimes I feel Apple makes those products to give message that you don't have your own value. Get our product.
That increase your value. Sometimes I maybe wrong [INAUDIBLE] happens more in Indians.
There are people who don't even know to use iPhone properly. They just know how to call..
They don't to use apps and anything but they get an iPhone just to do [INAUDIBLE]
That will add the value in because by getting such products.
I feel that [INAUDIBLE] If you really, if required and really then take it.
Speaker 1: When you personalized that,
so what is going to make you successful at the Indian market instead of other companies that come from abroad?
Speaker 2: So obviously being an Indian, I know the, I understand the mentality of the Indians.
I know what they exactly wants and what I should include in a product so that they will be easily fascinated
or they will be easily attracted towards a product, that would make them feel special.
So everything I am putting into consideration.
So like if people coming from abroad will think to make a product and to put in the market,
they will not understand exactly Indian mindset. Like you can see just recently, if I take the example of Apple.
They just decreased the price of the Apple. And the volume sales increased drastically.
So there might be some Indian in the Apple and they are [INAUDIBLE] might have suggested that if you do this [INAUDIBLE]
it is going to drastically increase the number of sales in India.
So if you want to [INAUDIBLE] on the Indians, it's a great market. It is more than 1 billion populace.
If you know in India so there is more [INAUDIBLE]
and the population is more than 1 billion so you can sell your products in the Indian market so.
If you follow some parameters and that [INAUDIBLE]
obviously if you are from Netherlands than you know better what product has to be done than that is going to
[INAUDIBLE] audience. Or the Netherland people.
I cannot go and I cannot get a [INAUDIBLE] product that will attract them.
If you, if there is a comparison if you saw a product and I saw a product, your product is going to sell.
But, the reverse will be in India.
If I make a product, which your product may be 100 times better than my product,
but I will be including something in that problem, might [INAUDIBLE] because I will knowing that [INAUDIBLE]
Indian mindset.
Speaker 4: [INAUDIBLE] the cost if there's any other
Speaker 1: Yeah, okay well you asked the question already. Are there other parts [INAUDIBLE]
Speaker 2: I told you the main parameter is that it should be [INAUDIBLE] such that [INAUDIBLE]
then low cost won't matter. Right to get the iPhone or to get the Samsung Galaxy type phone.
More costlier than the pocket money that [INAUDIBLE] get. I mean, they somehow get it anyhow.
They borrow from friend, they add all their pocket monies, and all of them they get their iPhone
or their Samsung Galaxy phone. Because that has created a noise. And that has created royalty to individuals.
Among a French community if you are using iPhone or a Samsung you get special treatment. Wow you have an iPhone..
Wow you have a Samsung Galaxy so people appreciate.
And there will be some kids, or some other students that will be jealous that people have that,
that his friend has an iPhone, and I don't have it. So that jealousy, to feel that royal-ness, people buy the product.
And that is more. That is the first thing by which people purchase that product.,
The people who really [INAUDIBLE] are coming into the secondary [INAUDIBLE] that creates a jealousy.
Speaker 2: If a product, if someone is feeling really special, and others are appreciating
and they are feeling jealous that this person has that product, it is creating a wow effect.
Everyone is appreciating wow you have this product. So that jealously will make others to get that product.
I don't know who wins. The company will be [INAUDIBLE] product wins.